i wanted to kind of bring them back to
you guys here because one of the talking
points is that this was an insurrection
these were terrorists they planned the
coup d'etat we have
john bolton the man who knows almost
everything about a coup d'etat because
he
orchestrated them in the third world
coming out and saying this was
definitely a coup d'etat
from your experience was this a
professional coup d'etat attempt
even well i mean what i saw going into
the capital
were some people who were intent on
breaking things but mostly a lot of just
kind of bewildered
people who were kind of bumbling about
and
and kind of taking in the novelty of it
and when i arrived in the rotunda
you know there were probably about 80
people in there and a lot of them were
just milling around
and taking selfies and and it didn't
seem like they were
you know trying to run around and smash
anything
um i i think really what what happens in
these kind of situations is
is once the chaos starts you know once a
couple of people break through that
line once a couple of people start
pushing up on the cops then it doesn't
take much
for other people to follow suit so so
let's just start from the beginning
and let's hear you guys a story what
happened well we'll start off with
well actually it's gonna start off in
the morning because you were there yeah
yeah so i got there
around um eight in the morning and as
soon as i arrived
at the washington monument it was just
like a sea of people you know flag
how many do you think i mean from my
perspective i think
minimum have over half a million people
i would
say in the hundreds of thousands i was
there for obama's first inauguration and
second and trumps
and it was not quite the same numbers as
any of those but
it was close half a million yeah let's
not forget is it half a million
i i mean i think i mean it was because
we for sure two hundred for sure
because the women's marks they said it
was around there and i looked at the
photos um you know the aerials and stuff
i mean it was hundreds of thousands
let's let's say that it's definitely
more than tens of thousands i think
so what happens what happens it's also
so so my understanding is that
trump got on stage and said you know
everybody standed attention and said
your orders are as such go
and destroy and then start passing out
torches right yeah like trump trump
directed all of them
like i said i got through kidding by
yeah yeah i know but when i even even
getting there like i said i got in
got it there eight in the morning it was
a sea of people it went all the way back
to like the washington monument
um when trump trump i think took the
stage around noon
and he spoke for about 45 minutes now
where i was at
you couldn't even like hear him so like
the people were just there to like kind
of be there
but even during his speech people
already started going to the capitol
building
so um like from where i was at you
couldn't hear anything but like i said
it seemed like a normal day
you know i was i was watching trump's
speech and it was
before anybody could have even left the
ellipse people were all ready
to get to the capitol so like trump and
the people who were there so i i knew
people who were down there and i was
asking almost like are you anywhere near
the capitol they're like no i'm at the
rally trump's giving a speech
i'm like but there are people at the
capitol building right now who were like
you know so anyway continue continue
what happened but basically yeah
i was more in the back section but even
even during trump's speech like i said
you
already see people flowing in and
heading towards the capitol building
so i did my interviews and then i
thought it was gonna be a regular day so
for me i was like you know what this is
my chance to like
go get some mcdonald's and like just
kind of like recharge be back at like
five for the action so
when i when i went to go do that um
that's when i got the news of
basically the the breach happened and i
think that's literally right as i was
going i think
richie then so i saw i actually had a
friend who worked
um at the capitol and they were up on
the up on the roof and they said they
saw cops running around
and i was like that's weird um i should
probably get down there
so i went down there and i bought i
brought all my gear because i
i didn't suspect that things were gonna
get bad but i wanted to be ready if they
did
and the moment i arrived i mean there
was you can see the clips my first clips
on
my thread on twitter it was basically
art they were already clashing and i
went up in that um
tower that scaffolding and you can see
that view as the lines are broken
basically it's the same thing you know
two or three guys make it through
they get clubbed they get knocked down
brutality everyone gets even more mad
and then a couple more breakthrough and
then the police are overwhelmed
and if you see the numbers i mean
it's not a matter i think that the
instances that have been cited online of
cops you know
letting up or whatever i don't even
think it was a matter of that because
even where i was where the cops were
giving it their 1000 i mean you can see
on the video these cops were trying
their best to hold on to these barriers
to hold the line
but they were getting pepper sprayed
themselves and i saw a number of them
injured and and going
back and getting medical attention so um
i think
they would have been overwhelmed no
matter what given the chaos that was
unfolding
so how did how did you so what happens
you're you're standing up on the
scaffold you see
the line break what happens next so i
see the line break and as the line is
breaking i have to give a shout out as
my mom's birthday
and i called her in the morning i'm not
that bad a son but she called me as the
line was breaking
and like on an iphone if you ignore the
call it ends the video
so then if you look on twitter my video
is broken up into three parts because
my mom called me a second time and i
declined again and i
she forgave me for ignoring her call on
her birthday so thank you mom
i appreciate that but um after that by
that point
the police were concentrating themselves
kind of in that open area on the stairs
but people are already climbing up the
scaffoldings and
into an area where they could still
access the the capitals
so actually the scaffoldings made it
more difficult for the cops to defend
that area surrounding because basically
that
there were you know like little nooks
and crannies where people could climb in
climb into those
scaffoldings climb up and get up on the
bleachers so then so what happens
like when did people get in take us
through
how you ended up in there from up there
i could see basically the flow of people
going up the stairs a lot of them just
stopped and decided to
wave a trump flag or you know wave
whatever flag they had
i caught video of one guy who got a fire
extinguisher for somewhere and was
spraying it down on the cops below him
yeah
um so when did they go inside so that it
was right around that time
that the lines broke and it took me
about ten minutes before i realized like
there's a there are a ton of people
going in there and i have
congressional press credentials so i was
like i'm going in i'm going to see
what's going on there
that's how you were up there in the
first place yeah um well no so i
actually just i
i had come down so quickly that yeah i
wasn't up there in the first place but
um by the time i got in there i saw
a bunch of people in the rotunda but
then to my left i saw some protesters
kind of rushing down
the hall through statuary hall towards
the house floor
so i went through statuary hall and
there was already like
evidence of some riot control munitions
being used
um you can see like the pepper on the
ground you know and and also
the orange tinge of uh pepper spray yeah
you know like it has a
red color depending on which brand it is
but um
so i proceeded down that hallway and i
actually saw a group of protesters
surrounding the house doors and there
were like eight or nine of them you can
see it on my video right as i arrive
and actually some of them are shouting
like you killed her you killed someone
you killed someone
and so they were already somehow aware i
think that was just immediately after
the shooting had taken place
and one of them had wedged himself right
in that door and i think that's the
photo that you see with the police with
their guns drawn right that guy with his
face right there
because the there were only two or three
police at the time they're actually
outnumbered right in front of the doors
and they were trying to pry him off but
because they were outnumbered they were
basically waiting waiting for
reinforcements
and it took about five to ten minutes of
kind of like a little
standoff before six or seven more cops
showed up and
and then removed them and we were pushed
back out into um
through statuary hall and into there
there's a clip where you're saying you
can't breathe and there's a cop saying
he can't breathe
what happened with that okay so that was
after we were pushed through statuary
hall we were back
into the capital rotunda which is the
big
underneath the big dome that's like the
biggest room there and there were still
you know maybe 100 people in there
the cops started to push us out but
there's there's kind of like a maybe
only a 20-foot wide
doorway there and so what happened was
all the protesters got bottlenecked
there
they were pushing back and then there
were maybe 40 or 50 cops at the time
pushing
against us so i was you know as a
reporter it's it's valuable to be in the
middle of
of the protesters and the cops so you
can kind of show both sides so i was
stuck
in between and i literally had you can
hear on the video one
the cop had his billy club on my stomach
and i was like can you just take it off
my tummy like please like my tummy put
it up here oh well i don't know why i
said that
i don't know why i said that but i think
it was easier for me to say
tummy than like stomach yeah i don't
know why
um but you could hear another you never
know how you act in a crisis people
people think
they know how they respond you don't
sometimes just blurt out tummy but it
felt a lot better once you got it up on
my vest why was he doing it
he was like holding you back or what so
he was pushing against me to try to push
the protesters back but
there were probably 30 protesters behind
me pushing against me so i literally was
just i mean i was telling the officers
like there's nothing
i can do and he was being pushed behind
by his own officers so
this is why you shouldn't go in between
yeah i understand what you mean but you
know you're trying to you're trying to
stand not necessarily
in between but like off but still sort
of like so you can see both groups and
what they're doing
because if you're behind the protesters
you won't see what they're exactly and
if you're behind the cops you don't see
what the cops are you got
you got to get that angle that's it's
tough and then you end up getting it was
like 20 minutes stuck in there
as just pushing back and forth wow but
then they broke through or what
um they eventually pushed the protesters
all out okay they cleared it out
yeah and and then there was another
scuffle by the
the door to the exit which had also been
smashed and they were trying to close
but the protesters were blocking that
and so that was like kind of the last
final push and i got
tossed into the door breaking news uh
this is pretty uh
big news by an ap reporter named mike
balsalmo who says quote u.s capitol
police say reports that an officer has
died are not
true although some officers were injured
and hospitalized yesterday
no uscp officers have passed away this
is again according to mike
balsalmo who is an ap reporter uh that
just
broke this story a couple minutes ago
and i didn't want to interrupt you no no
no no no no
here's the challenge for us here as with
that anything putting into news
i've got what 800 plus sources saying an
officer died of being hit and have the
fire extinguisher and we have one guy
saying it's not true so who do you trust
i actually know mike he does great work
right he does
i trust him i do do i do too i do too he
he did i can't remember
what he he covered some big events he
did uh what mike did was
was really cool is when during the
portland riots he got inside
access oh yeah federal officers so he
actually got to be in the land with him
right and he got to actually interview
and tell their story so yeah i i think
uh
i'll trust mike on that one uh but at
the same time we'll you know we'll we'll
see
we'll have to wait for things to kind of
i mean look it's really fascinating that
i mean we've got you know kron4 we got
cnn we got a bunch of sources saying
this officer died now he's coming out
saying the capital police are denying
that
it makes sense yeah sometimes you know
what happens is that cnn will get a
story and then everyone copy cnn and
cite them
and then someone goes for a comment goes
whoa you got to stop well tim
actually speaking of the the ap oh mike
um well i got there a little bit after
i guess um the crowd has already been
cleared out at the u.s capitol so it was
between
4 35 and as soon as i got there there
were still hundreds of folks at the u.s
capitol
and there was a lot of rage going on in
and um so i got on the ground
and uh the ap was actually they're still
reporting they had a couple camera i
believe they had about four cameras
tripods
the whole thing and the whole crowd just
starts turning on them
attacking them smashing their cameras
yeah then they took down their
barricades and then in my video you
could see one man with
american flagpole just you know trying
to hit them and then smack the cameras
down and then eventually the crowd just
destroys um the whole equipment and so i
i took that footage and then i
i uploaded on twitter then the the the
response online is
um you know folks we're just like
cheering it on and it's my mentality
that's why we use our cell phones and
look and i
get it you know there's a lot of anger
with with the with the mainstream media
but
i think for me as a takeaway with as a
reporter was you know
and maybe richard you have some thoughts
on this is like during the summer when
we filmed
press getting attacked from black lives
matter activists and we put that online
that same crowd would say hey these are
the anti-fascists
they're against you know the first
amendment they're against freedom of
press
yep but when it's their side it was
acceptable i think
that's a really interesting point and it
goes back to what you were talking about
with the small businesses earlier which
is
you know over the summer what we saw
were a lot of really
people who felt like they'd been sold
down the river and they were angry about
it
and uh that anger was
aimed towards a system that was enforced
by police and so the
the argument of blm and antifa is always
you know they infor
enforce a corrupt system therefore all
cops are bastards so
we saw that turn happen um
not this last rally but the one before
where all the proud boys were basically
saying
you guys are enforcing this system
that's stealing our election
therefore you guys are terrible but we
started seeing the sentiment against
police when the cops were enforcing the
coveted lockdowns
and some of them were perceived as
arbitrary by locals notably in staten
island
where you had this one bar that decided
to open up and define to the lockdown
but two blocks away
there's a restaurant with full like just
operating like normal
and so the locals get angry and they say
what's this all about why are we locked
down and they're not they say well
you're on the border of
the red zone so when the police come
come out and
block the door people in staten island
trump supporters come out with trump
flags
surprisingly thin blue line flags
yelling at the cops
and then it escalated when we actually
saw the conservatives take the thin blue
line flag throw it on the ground
stomp on it and then throw it in the
street and then i think
you know you've got conservatives saying
it's the birth of right-wing antifa well
it's important to point out in stan
island
the zone that was restricted the most
was a republican
area that many people said that the
local democratic government was
selectively choosing to enforce these
rules
they were also targeting the jewish
areas which is really weird
yeah the hasidic jewish community and we
talked about that extensively on this
show
and even had uh heshi on the show who's
still out there and uh going to many
rallies
i actually made my way up there and
covered a story with uh
with the hasidic jew community where
they just defied the lockdown orders and
kind of partied out
out and burn some masks yeah one of the
crazy things too i guess is just
people oh there's a lot of commentary on
the the wrong target i guess they're
saying why are you going to the capitol
building you know they're they're doing
this
i guess you call pro forma or ceremonial
uh electoral
you know account and it didn't matter if
it was i don't know or not
it doesn't matter if you're in the
capital where's the actual organization
and the tar and the protests of these
actual corrupt institutions
i get it they view the capital and
congress as corrupt in a lot of ways
but what about the media and what about
more importantly
organizing and planning so that what you
do is effective in some capacity
because now what we see here is already
there's joe biden coming out numerous
occasions now saying it was insurrection
domestic terrorism and things like that
so i you know we had the patriot act now
they're going to come out with the like
securing american freedoms
and and now we're seeing an argument to
remove trump from office
article amendment 25 there my question
is is
i think if that had been a blm march
then
perhaps the they would have had more
guards who was who's in charge of that
who i i honestly think whose job is it
to make sure that that capital doesn't
get attacked
it's capital police right there's park
police involved
muriel bowser and the federal government
who of those people
puffed up well it's the sorry messed up
fudge
it's the capitol police who uh who's now
resigned i suppose
but i think the issue is to look i think
it was it was
they screwed up but more importantly
nobody thought trump supporters were
gonna do this
come on i had my helmet and my gas mask
on yeah but
i guess we've seen the escalation i like
to mention with with cops and and you
know the proud boys fighting
but to like when you look at anti-fun
they're showing up and they've been
burning you know anti-fun blackouts
have been burning things down for years
they're like we better secure this
you get the ellipse full of a bunch of
middle-aged and older trump supporters
waving little flags
and trump giving a speech and they were
like man he's gonna be fine you know we
don't have anything to worry about
apparently they did the proud boys uh
the previous rally they weren't just
waving little flags they were
running through the streets shouting f
antifa and looking for fights sure they
got the fights
but to assume that the regular trump
supporters
would bolster that you know what i mean
would would escalate i agree with that
but i don't think it takes very many in
the group
in order to to create that kind of
situation and i think
you know what some people have said is i
i i can't believe i'm seeing people
that think it was a good strategy i
don't think it matters whether
i don't think that matters i you know
you know what man when we see corey bush
and aoc
they're calling for the expulsion of
members of congress who supported trump
she directly said that like ted cruz and
hawley should be expelled from
congress it's like okay like you're a
congresswoman they're senators that's a
very you know it's a bit different the
upper chamber
but that's an insane and dangerous
escalation
and it's going to keep happening nobody
wants to back down cnn doesn't
cnn is looking at their their cpms or
you know
on youtube perhaps they're looking at
their ad rates and their jeff zucker's
cracking the champagne and saying we got
to keep this going something
let's not forget there was our uh just a
month ago there was like reports of jeff
zucker wanting to step down because of
the trump administration so you know for
him he was like hey
i already wrote what i could do you know
we already hit the highest ratings we
can you know there's
under the biden administration you know
it's going to be you know lame duck
media
um so yeah there was already reports of
jeff suckers trying to step down but
with this it's going to you might want
to stay in business
so someone today took chris cuomo's
comments a few months ago where he said
protests are not supposed to be peaceful
they took the full segment
and instead of doing the b-roll of black
lives matter during the summer they
replaced it with what happened
in the capital and everyone's freaking
out about that video i mean obviously
it's doctored obviously it's fake but
doctor we have to understand you know a
lot of the bigger kind of mainstream
media institutions have kind of led
this kind of foundation this this
groundwork that it's
okay to use violence for political means
as long as it's your political meaning
exactly i mean
vox literally had an article that said
riots are destructive dangerous and
scary
but can lead to um serious political
reforms
this is what people are you know people
i got an email from someone saying tim
you're wrong about violence and they
were like look at all these things
throughout history where violence has
brought change and i'm like bro that was
400 years ago
like there was no mass media there's no
mass communication and so yes
one day somebody was leaving their farm
and went to town hall and saw a
different flag there and went what
happened and they were like oh he's in
charge now they're like oh
but we have to understand blm had the
support of the establishment of the
mainstream media
of attorney generals that literally let
off a lot of people
trump supporters don't have any of that
so that's why this was
a miscalculation this was a big misstep
and i think this was just
uh a fervent crowd just getting raised
so here's
the question though is that do you think
the conservative media's reaction
has been similar to what uh quote
unquote liberal media's reaction was to
the blm riots it's always like
well i don't i don't know specifically
but what i will say
conservatives especially like ben
shapiro will immediately come out
and condemn on principle things yeah
like if the violence is wrong if the
left does it
at the right time there's right wingers
detesting everything that happened
yesterday fox news
as it was happening had the the head guy
of cpac on
talking about how it was justifiable to
assassinate and kill an unarmed woman
who he thought at the time was a
teenager was that match lap
yeah match slap was literally so so fox
news already
was saying this is disgusting this is
horrible this is bad the people deserve
to die when they were shot unarmed by
the cops that's that's the messaging
that was coming out on fox a lot
different
than of course msnbc saying oh this
protest is mainly peaceful
everything is there's a there's a police
station on fire behind the guy
yeah now now i know there's a fire but
it's mostly peaceful
and now these same people are lecturing
us about how
everyone who was there whether innocent
or not whether bad or not whether doing
something illegal or not
deserves to be sent to jail for the
maximum amount of time
we deserve to lose our civil liberties
we do we deserve to lose our speech
because this happened and this is bad
and this is horrible because violence
should be detested at all costs
meanwhile they are cheering it on just a
few weeks ago thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you